from nfl game day morning he sits two
seats down the road he's in the pro
football hall of fame he is the lead
analyst for westwood one radio's
coverage of the national football league
and he is going to be there on thursday
night
one week from last night to talk about
what's going down in the nfl draft with
me and everybody else on nfl network
he's my buddy
kurt warner how are you kurt i am doing
really really good rich i'm uh
excited about this next week and uh you
know to get some of the speculation out
of the way and then start talking about
next fall
well i don't know um i might be breaking
news to you kurt uh the speculation's
already
done for the top six picks because
yes i just i just started the show i
conducted my
uh rich eisen uh mock draft come at me
2.0 um and making my picks i backed it
up by shaking this magic eight ball that
i have right here
and the six out of six right chris
signs points yes you know
well come at me tell me what the first
six are okay here you go you ready
here's my
here it is it's uh trevor lawrence i'm
on fire right
uh zach wilson okay then i think the
niners are gonna go trey lance curt
i think they're gonna wind up looking at
a trailer oh you went higher register
there and i did two
which means we might not believe it uh
kyle pitts for atlanta then pine sewell
and uh jamar chase for the bengals and
the dolphins what do you think
okay all right i mean i can see that i
mean
i think we're all intrigued by number
three right we've heard so much mac
jones
um and you know people wondering okay is
mack jones give you that big upside that
makes you go all the way up there to get
him or
is it as you're talking about a trey
lance or even a justin fields that
may have a bigger skill set across the
board so i think that's the
fascinating pick um where it really
really starts the draft
is there at number three let's get into
it kurt what is your evaluation
of what you think the niners are
evaluating right now
and who do you think is uh is the third
overall pick
that's a lot to chew on i'll give you
the floor there is
and it's fascinating because uh
first of all we have to remember that
they have jimmy garoppolo in the
building
and so that's the first place that i
always start because i go okay you have
jimmy we know what jimmy is we know that
jimmy helped you get
to a super bowl we know that he's won a
lot of games and so we know what his
skill set is
and so i see that and then you know
there's a lot of speculation about mac
jones
and i like mack jones i think mac jones
plays the game
very much like i did from a cerebral
standpoint and processing information
and understanding how to make different
throws
but there's a limit there with what he
is physically now i don't know what that
limit
is you know i've kind of likened it in
some of the other interviews i've done
rich
to kind of myself on one end because
that's how i played the game
uh but i believe that i had kind of a
bigger upside
you know physically where i could make
some of those special kinds of throws
even though i wasn't a great athlete i
could play the position a little more
athletically
and then you have an andy dalton who
plays the game very similar to that and
a starter in this league and has won a
lot of games and played in
in playoffs but doesn't have that that
upside physically that i believe can
carry a team and and get a team to that
next level he needs that help
around him to be able to do that and so
where does mac jones fit in that mix is
he more
kurt warner is he more andy dalton
somewhere in between but what is his
physical upside but so i compare him to
a jimmy g
and i say okay what are you getting from
mac jones that you don't have
with jimmy g now is it simply jimmy g
can't stay healthy
okay i get it we want a guy that
processes and that can play within
kyle's offense because he's so good at
creating opportunities and is accurate
you know a guy like jimmy g
but a guy that we believe can stay
healthy and so we go get another guy
so that's to me is the argument for a
mac jones
or there's the argument that kind of
lends itself to what you did there
at three and you say okay if we're gonna
make all these moves and we're gonna go
up to number three
we need to get something more than we
believe we have in jimmy garoppolo
and that is you know what's the
different skill set now i think jimmy's
really talented in a lot of ways
and is a solid athlete but he's not the
athlete that a trae lancer justin fields
is
and so that becomes the other side where
you go well if you're going to do that
you must be going up to get something
different
something that gives you an advantage in
a different way
and may lend itself to one of those
other two guys
but i don't know what the answer to that
question is i don't know if they're
looking at it more just hey jimmy hasn't
stayed healthy so we need to find
another guy
to place in here with all our pieces and
i could definitely see mac jones go
there
but i could definitely buy into those
other two guys
and you have jimmy there so trey lance's
in your pick rich
to me has maybe the best skill set of
all these guys
when you look at the complete picture i
also think he's got the most work to do
of all these guys so you have jimmy
there and you say hey
we go get trey lance we got a perfect
position to let him
sit for a year to learn for us to teach
him
and then for us to run to him uh in a
couple years and let him be that guy
when he's got a year of seasoning under
his belt
so i can see a lot of different
arguments there and i'm excited to see
you know as we all speculate what it is
really that kyle shanahan and john lynch
are thinking for them to make the moves
that they did give up as much as they
did to get up to number three
kurt warner here on the rich eisen show
it just seems to me
you know kurt to use what you just said
you know another guy
who doesn't leap off the page with a
physical skill set
either at the position is tom brady
right
and so and he's one we don't need to go
into it
so so here's the deal it just feels like
this day and age right now 2021 the way
that you're seeing the position being
played
the way that you see mahomes the way
that you see lamar jackson and we could
go on and on
kyler murray it seems to me trading all
that capital to get up to three to take
somebody who doesn't
have as you said the other physical
skill set
to matriculate the ball down the field
to be a dual threat to use that to go
get
that guy despite how impressive he may
be
in interviews and the fact that he is a
national champion and he
has the alabama coaching staff that has
downloaded into him and his
self-madeness
that he is it just doesn't compute
to do that it just does not compute kurt
what do you say to that
i think um our computations are
different
is that i believe that can still win and
will always win
in the nfl it meaning the mac jones the
tom brady
the ability to process information
uh and get through progressions and get
it to the right guy
and know how to anticipate i believe
that will always win
now we all want that plus right we want
that guy
plus the physical things that give us an
advantage
but we can look at all these incredibly
talented quarterbacks
and what we always come back to with
them especially when it comes playoff
time
i believe you can win in this league
meaning regular season
with athleticism with talent when you
start to play good teams week after week
in the playoffs
you better be able to make the layups
you better be able to see the field
process and get the ball out and win on
time
and not expect to be able to win with
athleticism
and so i believe that the mac jones and
again
i i don't know what mac jones physical
upside is you have to have a level of
physical upside
again i likened it to myself you could
tom brady's another one
that he can do things and make special
throws with his right arm now it doesn't
look like running around for three
seconds
and making a throw but he's still making
special throws
so you have to be able to do that at the
quarterback position but if you can
process information
and get the ball out on time you can win
at you know at the nfl level and i
believe you can compete for
championships
by doing that and you know even with the
patrick mahomes
we know he's physically gifted and he
does crazy things with his arm
but i've made the argument for two years
what makes him special
is what he does with his mind his
creativity to see things
and to play on schedule and then do the
extra is what's made him
so unique and so um i understand your
point and i believe that's where people
are leaning because we've never seen the
quarterback position
played as athletically as we see it
played now
but look at those athletic quarterbacks
and
how many are competing for championships
each and every year
so you have to be able to find the
balance and i believe specifically at
playoff time
to be able to play at a high level
inside the pocket i think josh allen's a
great example
here's an athletic quarterback for the
first couple years of his career
we talked a lot about what he did with
his legs and yeah he did some things
with his legs last year but what really
took him
to the next level was his ability to
complete passes and
to be accurate and his accuracy went up
into the high 60s
and we're seeing them play inside the
pocket differently
and that's what helped their team get to
the afc championship game
you still have to be able to do that so
i believe if you can start there
you can win in this business and then
it's what extra do you give me when i
need a little bit extra
and that can show up in a lot of
different ways all the way from tom
brady
to russell wilson and all the different
things in between so in the few minutes
i have left with you here kurt warner
let's evaluate these quarterbacks we'll
place trevor aside i'm sure we'll see
some
exo that you'll have on nfl network and
part of the draft coverage next week
that shows his incredible ability and
what
you think he needs to work on we'll
place that aside i'll ask you about the
number two overall pick here
and understand that your answer not only
affects somebody who you're talking to
right now who i assume you still have
great affection
uh for but also your own flesh and blood
there's somebody in your own household
who does love the new york jets god
bless election
okay so um so is zach wilson the right
pick
too overall come on
well i'm gonna say i believe he's the
right pig okay um and
again i break him he does things
athletically at the quarterback position
and again
i always look at things differently when
a lot of people look at athletic
they look at how fast you run the 40 and
and what your body
style is and can you run the zone read i
look at the ability to throw
the football athletically in the pocket
and
like the perfect example is patrick
mahomes his ability to make different
kinds of throws and creatively
process and see how he needs to make
different throws is unique and special
to me zach wilson has that in him
now in the offensive byu and the
competition i didn't see enough
to know exactly what he can be at the
next level
but his skill set says to me yes he's
the right guy at number two
and i believe my imagination and many of
our imaginations have been
kind of captured by patrick mahomes when
i looked at patrick mahomes in college
i saw a lot of the same things that i
saw on zack wilson
and also had some questions about him
coming out
now he's shown me once he got to the
league oh okay
i was missing some things i didn't
understand what he was
mentally and now i'm seeing that at the
nfl level
i'm allowing my imagination i think to
grab a hold of a little of what patrick
mahomes has done
and kind of hope it on to zach wilson
that he's got the skill set
he's got a unique right arm uh he's got
the ability to
see how to make different throws which
is all stuff that i believe
translates now does he have a little of
that mental
uh like a patrick mahomes that can
really take him to the next
level and when i put all those things
together yes i believe he is the right
fit
and the right guy to pick it number two
because of some of the other questions i
have with the other three guys
and because of that unique skill set so
i do see zach wilson going there
and i do believe it is the right pick
when i look at these five guys
excellent so what about three you think
it's jones give me your best guess
based on your evaluation the eye in the
sky you're mr qb confidential at
qbdconfidential.com is something you're
building
yeah um so let's go what do you got for
me
you know it's funny as much as i can see
mac jones going there i don't think it
is
and i i simply do that because i say i
have jimmy g
and it looks to me like they made this
move to go get something different
and something that they believe can be
more now
that puts me at justin fields or trey
lance
and i just believe justin fields is the
better of the two quarterbacks based on
what i've seen in college
complete upside trey lance could be the
best of these five when it's all said
and done because he's got
all the things that you want but it's
just not as seasoned yet
and so to me if i'm picking between
those other two guys
based on what i've seen to this point uh
the consistency
playing at a high level what he did the
last couple i'm going justin fields
there
at number three because he gives me a
little bit something different than what
i have in jimmy g
but he's got a body of work and a level
of consistency
that to me puts him a little bit ahead
of trey lance at this point
in the game and then with the falcons to
use your
your philosophy here about what you
currently have and who you could bring
in that's different
um but you could also bring in somebody
completely unique and kyle pitts for
someone that you have like mike ryan
for his final window of opportunity in
atlanta
what do you think atlanta is going to do
it for
yeah right that's a great question um
i mean i love pitts i mean i think he's
a difference maker
um with the talent but we also know that
you have to have the quarterback
position and
you know a lot of these teams at this
point start to come down to
do we want to go the green bay packer
route where we want to have two decades
of success because we're more than that
because we have
a quarterback position solidified we
know matt ryan is getting towards the
end
do you go and get that guy a trey lamp
type guy where you go hey maybe we have
two or three years left
with um with matt and trey will be ready
to go and he'll give us another decade
of success at that position or as you
said do you go the route that hey we got
a couple more years with matt ryan
at his peak let's surround him and let's
go try to get that championship that we
weren't able to get
a few years back when we got to the
super bowl um
yeah uh you know i wrestle back and
forth i mean you know me i'm i'm all
about the quarterback
yes and so i believe if you've got one
of those guys that you really like and
believe could be
a decade-long starter and a really good
elite player
at that position sitting up at number
four i think you have to do that and you
have to go get one of those guys
and let him let matt ryan groom him and
get ready to go in a couple years and
hopefully make a similar type run to
what the packers have done with
with aaron rodgers not seeing any of
these guys as aaron rodgers but
you know have that success for another
decade plus
um you know with that guy behind center
lance fitzware
everywhere i mean like where would he
fit in case you everything that you just
said kind of drops if
maybe for the falcons to take pits where
does he know
i think lance is intriguing because he
has everything you know he's got the
physical uh you've seen him do
some really really good things throwing
the football i just think there's
there's an inconsistency there that he
needs more time
and so i think the perfect fit is
somewhere like in atlanta
where you go hey we still got a guy we
don't have to rush trade lance into this
thing
and so that's why you know your picket
at three with san francisco
also can make sense to me because we do
have jimmy g we got a guy we can win
with i know our team is ready to win
we can do that with jimmy g and we can
allow trey to come along because i
i do believe trey and we got to put that
caveat out there rich that most of the
film we've seen on trey lance
was two years ago right and so that's
the hard thing too is to know exactly
what he is
right now but based on that film i think
he needs to go somewhere where he
truly can sit uh for a period of time
and they can groom him into the offense
and he can learn how to be a pro and he
can work on some of those
inconsistencies he has and then he can
take over and run with this thing so
in atlanta even a san francisco to me
makes sense but a situation like that
to me is the perfect fit for for a guy
like trey lands kurt warner um
can't wait to see you in ohio part of
the draft coverage uh and part of that
draft coverage this time around kurt
is going to be my run for st jude that i
did this past weekend i know you were on
vacation but we
we we announced it on wednesday i don't
know if you heard the circumstances
surrounding it
i did not okay talk to me uh eight nfl
legends
uh were running with me including your
team
yes eight nfl legends and eight
very very deep pocketed and very very
very
uh big-hearted donors uh donated over a
million dollars for the right to run
with these legends at sofie
stadium yes one of them was tory holt
one of them was tory holt who looked
amazing
that's awesome okay reason why i bring
it up kurt not only because you know you
you are a big hearted as well
is because i thought of you kurt i
thought of you on this day
because warming up on the field there
was a football put out there
and i was throwing it what's the one
thing you love to make fun of me about
the most
kurt what is it what is it i i do love
watching you so
okay you do love watching me so here i
am out on the field your
your name and voice and laugh that you
just had popped into my head
as jerry rice who ran asked me to put
the ball
right on target with his tiptoes on the
sideline he wanted it in a certain spot
and guess who delivered it with zip kurt
warner guess who
yes well are we gonna see that as part
of the draft
yes you you bet damn straight yes
i love the run and i love that you made
a lot of money for st june that's
awesome but i can't wait to see the
throw oh yeah i need
i need to see this row but i am just
surprised that you didn't call me for
the run i mean
not necessarily because i'm a legend but
just i would have probably been the only
one that was in your realm
in terms of uh you know the race and the
speed
part of it so i'm surprised you didn't
call some guys like me to maybe uh
you know run run pace you cancelled in
that 40. careful what you wish for
because we're going to keep expanding
this each year
as i just explained to you we've
definitely expanded it this year but
i'll i'll tell you man you were in my
head as i'm standing back there there's
jerry rice saying put it right here
and i heard you in the back of my head
laughing and i'm like okay
i i didn't really step into it but i
zipped it there man i got it there
so i cannot wait to show you go on that
for the draft
yes we need to exhale that
i just stepped in it that's no good uh
kurt uh i'll see you out in uh
in in ohio best of brenda we'll we'll
chat soon all right buddy look forward
to it you gotta check out kurt's work at
quarter qbconfidential.com
and also at kurt 13 warner hey you
watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here